coming up Emily Lambert senior writer
for Forbes magazine examines the history
and purpose of the Board of Trade
mercantile exchange and other futures
markets she speaks it afterwards
bookstore in Chicago
it's about 45 minutes
so I I am much more comfortable
interviewing people than I am speaking
so I I'm sure that will come across very
quickly but thank you very much for
coming thank you so much to Beverly for
having this event and for hosting it it
this just happens to be my favorite
bookstore I have bought many a book here
I love coming here and of course it
turns out that Beverly has a connection
to this industry because in Chicago who
doesn't and I started talking to her and
she said oh yes my uncle grew up with
Leo Mohammed and then I went out to
breakfast the other morning with the
trader from the Board of Trade who said
that he used to work for Beverly's
father and I thought of course because
again it's Chicago and everybody seems
to have a connection to the trading
business so I just guy I would say a few
things about writing this book and then
I'm going to interview a trader because
that seems much more fun than listening
to me talk so I I'm first of all why I
wrote this book I moved to Chicago in
2004 for Forbes and it just seemed that
I seemed to meet a lot of traders
everywhere I went
we rented an apartment to start in
Lincoln Park and took up tennis which we
played very badly and Ray Kahneman a big
trader
played tennis on the next court
regularly so then another time we went
to the lakefront and I was reading a
book about the dummies guide to futures
and options because it just seemed that
it was a big local business and I should
learn more and some guy came up to me
and tapped me on the shoulder and was
like it's going to get easier and I said
oh that's good because I was reading
about some I think it was a butterfly
trade and options and it just seems like
craziness and this is all meeting all
these traders seem really interesting
and
you know I just got curious and of
course the Chicago Board of Trade
building is absolutely gorgeous and I
was curious as to what went on inside
and there seem to be a lot of news going
on in the industry which to anybody in
the industry of course might find kind
of you know obvious but in 2004 there
was a lot going on so I started covering
the industry and then I wrote a couple
of stories I wrote a story about the
merger of the two exchanges I got a call
from a book publisher who said do you
think that there's more to say about
these traders and I thought well of
course because it's the traders are such
interesting people there must be
something and this was 2008 when the
financial crisis was happening when oil
prices were going crazy when food prices
were going crazy I wasn't really sure
what I was going to write but I thought
sounds like fun write a book and in
retrospect that would be most naive
thing I could have possibly ever you
know done because the more that I
learned about the industry and learns
about traders and and learns about the
history of this place the more I felt
like I was taking on just a very big
project and also a very kind of personal
project for people in the industry I
mean there are people here who whose
families have been hearing for
generations and I suddenly thought Who
am I to to be you know coming and
sweeping in and writing this story but
I'm I'm glad I did because the it really
the futures industry is all about risk
and I guess in my case it was just one
of those naive risks which I hope paid
off because I I've really enjoyed it and
I've really enjoyed meeting the people
who I've met so I I just want to say I
you know how I actually had the good
fortune to meet up with Emily
turned out one day I was out having
lunch with a good friend of mine a guy
it's been exchanged a lot longer than I
have in fact he represented the
generation ahead of mine
Maurice Schneider and I whose son is
here whose son is here and that you know
and I was telling Maury I said you know
it's you know I'm a third-generation
trader myself you know the older guys
are fast disappearing and you know I
really wish that somebody out there was
really collecting stories to really
write the history of this very exciting
industry something that was such an
important component of the Chicago
economic history and more said to me
what are you talking about there's this
gal she's doing it right now
and so of course the first thing I did
was get Emily's phone number and call
her I think an hour later introduce
myself because I really wanted to do
what little I could to help her to make
this a very successful book that she's
writing which I appreciate and and which
also I should add that this is not to me
this feels like a first of all it's more
than Chicago economic history it is
Chicago economic history but features
have you know transformed the financial
system in ways that I think that people
don't fully maybe appreciating they
didn't don't realize and that goes for
traders as well as for people now who
are wrestling with these big concepts
like derivatives and an understanding
where they came from and understanding
what happened here I think is a story
that really hasn't been told very much
and I and I'm not so silly as to think
that it's completely told in this book
either I mean I'm hoping that this is
this is a I've scratched the surface of
what I think is really interesting
history and it deserves a lot more
attention and I I know I have more
stories in my notes that didn't make it
in so I hope that I can to add to this
record after this and another time
because they're just really is so much
here so yeah so I asked bill to talk
because I was hoping that he might be
able to
explain to people who aren't in the
industry who are here what I'm even
talking about it all because his family
very much mirrors the the story at the
futures industry Canon Chicago so there
are maybe you could just start if you
don't mind but what is the futures
contracts right I know you know a lot of
people that think that it's a very
mysterious arcane type of business but
futures contracts are essentially
insurance products that are and that was
the reason that the industry first
developed it was futures contracts are a
way to to offset risk on the part of
both people who need to use commodities
and people who produce commodities and
very simply a futures contract is a
contract between a buyer and a seller
for a specific commodity a specific
price for a specific future delivery
date and I guess you know the easiest
way to explain it in terms of how it's
used by people to offset risk I think
one of the simplest examples is you take
an airline company someone who needs to
use a lot of fuel on a regular basis and
of course if fuel prices go up that can
have a severe adverse impact on their
profitability so an airline company
realizing that fuel that crude oil is at
80 dollars a barrel and they're
concerned that it may go to $100 a
barrel they have the ability to purchase
all they need at a given price of $80
knowing that that will be their final
cost for the product so they use futures
because they they have too much risk
right they want to shove it off onto
some other people right and I think what
makes this such a fun business is that
Chicago has all these people who are
willing to take that risk well that's
the other side you know the real
economic reason for having futures
contracts is for those who want to avoid
risk but it certainly also provides a
great opportunity for those who want to
assume risk in search of profits so
Darrin that's the speculator
no secular so there's the
during the speculator there are two four
four people who are traders this is
boring stuff because you know it but for
people who aren't in the businesses
might be really interesting there are
two exchanges there are very different
places your family was that one of them
the Chicago Mark so can you who came
first the Board of Trade came first was
Boris Jenkins first let me react that
who in your family came first said to
the mole my grandfather hi Henner was
the first member of the hunter family to
add to trade and he went to the merc I
believe in the early 40s he started
trade in there
back when they were still trading onions
and but I think he primarily traded in
the egg markets so and and what was to
your knowledge what was the the Merc
like then you know it was a much much
smaller building I had actually I went
to work for the first time at the old
Merc in 1969 when I was all of 16 years
old I had a summer job working there and
at that time I think there were a total
of 500 members most of them weren't even
there on any given day so it was a you
know probably three maybe four 300 or so
actual live traders on the floor it was
much much smaller I remember you know
there were only really three products
that were trading there were hogs there
were cattle and there was the the real
you know most important contract which
was frozen pork bellies so and tell me
about the pork belly pit so how did
people trade it they traded it in pits
and talk about that and then you had
your uncle was in the pork belly fit
your uncle as far as I know was the
meanest person to ever walk through
that's that reputation I don't know if
it's completely deserved but you know
certainly I think you know it was
essentially the game face his pit
persona you know he was one of the
old-school guys who felt that you know
that you had to really put on a tough
front and you know he wasn't afraid to
use intimidation to further his business
interests and
it was very funny because my uncle had
you know after getting that reputation
it was very common among the order desks
on the floor whenever there was a new
clerk who had just was just starting off
at the exchange the the kind of rite of
passage was to give this poor kid a bad
order and send him to my uncle bill
Henner you know essentially they would
give him a live cattle order and send it
to my uncle and the pork belly pit so
and then they would watch the ensuing
that fireworks that would go off when my
uncle would browbeat this poor kid and
tell him he's a complete [ __ ] and you
didn't deserve to be at this place and
so on Victor and of course that the
order desk would have a great bit of
amusement around that and and these are
the kinds of stories that it took me a
while to understand what that meant or
did because there were different pits
where different things were traded and
so if you had an order for live cattle
it had to go to the live cattle pit
right so someone took an order for the
live cattle pit to the wrong pit then it
was they were right well generally
speaking you know that they would say no
no this is a live cattle or you need to
take it over there young man
but my uncle had reacted a little more
interestingly than that but you know in
his defense when he was not trading he
was a very generous man
he helped lots of people you know in in
the industry and I think it you know he
had wound up he had four wonderful
children that are all very good people
as well I and I spoke to to a woman who
was a clerk for your uncle who said that
she loved being a clerk for your uncle
because everyone had to pay her respects
because they didn't want to to have her
go get bill and himself nobody wanted to
be treasurer
right so so you were there also when
futures kind of left the world of
Agriculture and moved into the world of
finance and this is a big this is a big
step to leave what was essentially a
the world of commodities is that into
the world right language was always
assumed that the futures markets had to
be about agricultural products and you
know and in fact you know it there was
it was a very novel idea to introduce
the idea of having financial futures and
interesting enough actually that
happened during the time when I was not
involved in industry I I worked there in
1969 I went away to college the year
after that and that actually didn't
return to Chicago to get back into the
business until 1978 and the Merck had
changed dramatically in that ten-year
period actually nine-year period it had
moved from a very small facility at 110
North Franklin to a much much larger
building at 444 West Jackson when I came
back there were there not only were the
the agricultural markets but there was a
gold futures contract that was doing
enormous volume there were I think five
currency contracts that were each doing
very well and within the first year that
I came back they had introduced a
Treasury bill futures contract which was
kind of the precursor for the euro
dollar contract thank him along in 1982
who were some of the big big traders and
big personalities on the floor when you
came back
well when I came back you know there
were you know I think you know there was
there were some certainly big traders I
think you know the cattle market was
certainly being dominated by ref Coe and
Tom Dittmer I mean I remember the the
rumors would go across the floor Dittmer
spying cattle and you know people would
run to the cattle pit to try and
coattail him they were you know I
remember in the in the hogs and bellies
Joel Greenburg was it was a real big
player as well some [ __ ] and I
remember Joel Greenburg actually moved
into the Treasury bill Pitt and became a
very very large trader there for a while
I was well and so what did you join
I started off after I came back to
Chicago I worked as a clerk for a few
months than least deceit and I started
trading gold futures at the time other
than live cattle gold futures were
actually the second largest volume
product at the Mercantile Exchange that
part of it was due to the fact that in
those days people were utilizing what
they called gold spreads buying one
contract selling another is a vehicle to
actually defer taxes and buy defer you
may not pay yes they were what they have
use they were able to use gold contracts
to essentially take a tax liability from
one year and move it into the next year
and some people did that year after year
after year the problem was eventually
the government changed the regulations
and people could no longer roll their
tax and they say yes all of a sudden as
some people wanted with multi-million
dollar tax bills that were immediately
do okay so and and quite honestly I
think that was the end of the ability to
roll taxes through gold spreads was sort
of the beginning the end of the gold
contract at the Merck alpha business
actually wanted moving to new york and
then after so now keep going forward in
time for the 80s the 80s were the heyday
of trading in chicago right so what was
what was it like and then i want to ask
you about the boys well I think you know
the two most important new developments
at the Merck in the 80s were the
introduction of the Eurodollar futures
contract and then the introduction of
the S&P 500 can you just can you
describe what the Eurodollar pit looks
like in the Teta Eurodollar which was
incredibly packed with people i mean it
was a place where there was absolutely
no extra real estate available in fact
at one point one of the big brokers
there decided he was going to leave the
business and he was able to sell his
spot in the pit just enough room for one
person to stand for a million dollars
and but it was that and what hey what
makes our dinner of you what made that
spot so fantastic well the fact that
they were doing so much volume in the
Eurodollars contract that a good broker
in in the euro dollars was making more
in a month than a good broker in the
cattle would make in a year it was so
busy that clerks who were there to just
process order flow to get the orders
from the desk and tell the broker what
he needed to do were being paid six
figures at one time hmm and you you told
me once about a lunch you want to I
think how much you spent on a well yeah
you know Dec in the days when we were
doing quite well I we we used to take
turns buying lunch for the other two
people in the group and if the running
joke was to see how high they could run
the bill you know expensive champagne
old Armagnac things like that along with
a fancy meal and so how I did you make
it that's sometimes in excess of $1,000
for a lunch and times were good back
then you know the markets was very
inefficient and being on the trading
floor was just an incredible advantage I
mean if you are willing to be
disciplined to be careful you know you
could make a lot of money without taking
a very much risk some people manage to
do without taking any risk ethic so so
now things have changed the floor is not
what it was certainly the markets are a
lot more electronic the board of trades
which we haven't talked about but maybe
we can at least in in questions and the
mark are one big company now it's a very
different situation the and your family
you've been there for forage and three
generations now is there going to be a
fourth in trading I I think it's
unlikely honestly I never know I had I
don't have any children that are
particularly interested in in trading
but you know I think you know definitely
electronics just completely changed the
industry and it's changing in a way that
ultimately
has allowed the volume to go to numbers
that we could not have imagined 20 years
ago and ultimately it's provided a much
fairer even playing field for most of
the participants you know the the
professionals in the game no longer have
the ability to react faster to to get
better prices and to have any real
advantage over the normal retail trader
and so what did the Mercs people think
of the Board of Trade and then perhaps
we could have someone in the Board of
Trade contingent here address that you
know I think I'm not sure why there was
essentially such a ongoing culture clash
you know at but but the board in The
Merck never could seem to really you
know get together I mean there were I
there was talk of merging the two
exchanges back when I started in the
business and for one reason another that
they could never get together I don't
know if it was the egos of the people
who are running the exchanges and it was
always kind of a interesting thing that
you know the board of trade people I
think always had an attitude that they
were they were first and they had their
exchange was a more legitimate entity
than the Merc I think there was always
that that attitude that the Merc was
sort of the second rate exchange down
the street and we were just talking to
somebody before this who who said that
the Merc was the the juvenile exchange
did be that was the nickname for the
Merc that what did you have a nickname
for the board that I'd not that I recall
i I Rachel I was fortunate that you know
actually my father had memberships at
both exchanges and he actually had his
office in the Board of Trade building
and you know I think even though he
predominantly traded Mercantile Exchange
products he I think you know always
liked the Board of Trade better in fact
he hid and originally encouraged me to
to go to work at the board instead of
the Merck he said it was a more
civilized place and
and why did you end up at the Merc I
think part of it was just youthful
rebellion and and I think that's and
that's honestly why I think I I when I
started the business I didn't want to
trade agricultural products I was really
excited about the new financial futures
markets and I felt that ultimately they
would be where the big volume was going
to occur and that's why I started off in
gold and then soon moved into foreign
currencies because I realized that the
foreign currency market was potentially
the biggest trade of all and do you
think you what do you think people did
do you think that people today
understand what futures are outside the
industry outside you know I think
there's still that that that same
confusion in the minds of most people
and you know that's why you know there's
you know even had so much fun with it in
various movies you know futures industry
has always been kind of this arcane
subset of the financial industry and
very few people understand it even
though it is really not that difficult a
concept once you sit down and take a
look at it thank you is does anyone have
any questions if not I might target
people actually I want to say one more
thing and that is you know when I when I
was working as a runner before the
advent of financial futures the the
biggest trade at the Mercantile Exchange
was pork bellies and it did actually I
think 90% of the volume in the 60s and
the pork belly contract actually this
year 2011 is the 50th anniversary of the
introduction of that contract and just
last month there was an article in The
Wall Street Journal talking about pork
bellies how pork bellies were actually
the mercantile exchange was often
referred to is the house that bellies
built mm-hmm and as of last November six
contracts traded in pork bellies at the
Chicago Mercantile Exchange so you know
it's one of those things that is not a
certainly you know
on it appears to be on its way out and I
noticed that and I also realized that
you know last year was I think the first
year in seventy years that there wasn't
somebody with the last name hunter
trading at the Chicago Mercantile
Exchange hmm you know it's kind of sad
to see things change but you know
certainly the exchange itself the volume
is healthier than it's ever been and
then it's a story of market evolution
right and I'm really look Emily was
there during an amazing time of
innovation and so now then it's almost a
new era of innovation but questions any
questions yes Emily you mentioned you're
not from around here and as someone from
a SIBO family trading family broker
family I want to ask you you know you do
a good job in the book talking about how
the exchanges are sort of clannish and
obviously when you're generations of
people you know there's family secrets
and stories and things but not always
ones that they want the general public
to know how did you get people to talk
to you how did you get people to open up
to get so many good stories and
obviously so many that maybe you know
you'll you'll be able to tell us later
when I am and over drinks and no no I
did not
isn't happen here the UM the well first
of all I covered the industry for a
couple years before I wrote the book and
I think that was really helpful because
then people knew who I was and then were
able to vouch for me because you're
right this industry is incredibly
clannish and you have to have people say
you know essentially make an
introduction to other people it was for
example and everybody knows someone but
it really is all about introductions the
way I found bill was through the
Schneider's the way I found the
Schneider's was by calling people at the
New York Mercantile Exchange it's all it
really is a just it's a game of
telephone where everybody knows someone
and then I think this was just a unique
time where that the because things are
going electronic because the the clubs
are no longer actual clubs and they're
public publicly traded companies because
there's a period of transition people
are able or at a point where they're
more willing to look back and talk
perhaps than they were before so I think
that that helped I don't think I also
think that Emily's credit she has to
write was so you didn't know what was
going to be at burn piece you know I
mean a lot of types people come in and
they wants to I probably owe law or they
want the dirt on somebody I think she
has some very good well organized
questions where he didn't mine answer it
took me five or six meetings with her
before I actually told her the truth but
okay Jerry you just have to see which
angle she was coming from because a lot
of people try to come into our business
write a book and it look all for the
negative it's same as the Wall Street
Journal reporter he wants to negative
because it's gonna be on the front page
instead on the 12 page so her credit I
think she did a research higher homework
well animal and I do want to say that
it's easy to find the negatives in this
business and I'm not trying to hide them
either and I think it's part of the
history of the place but I feel like a
lot of people focus a lot on the
negative and we miss what actually works
about the industry and I think that
especially now when we look at what's
happened with the derivatives business
and things it's I think it's important
to go back and learn from history also
but what what works in history so Larry
Schneider can I can I ask you a question
which is that you started when you when
you started it was also the six days
correct I started working as a runner in
1967 also at 110 or Franklin also
internal Franklin and how little did
people know about the industry at that
time how little did people know about
the Mercs nobody knew anything about the
industry nobody knew anything about the
Mercantile Exchange is you know bill
said there's only 500 members and many
of those were New Yorkers who held the
for corporate purposes the Board of
Trade he had maybe 1300 members and you
know there'd only be a handful of clerks
for each brokerage firm there wasn't as
large as it is today so the story that
you're leading up to it's 1968 and I'm
in the elevator 1/2 North Franklin and
two women come in and one says to the
other isn't there some kind of Stock
Exchange in this building and the other
says yes but it's a small one and I
wanted to stop the elevator say excuse
me ladies it is a futures exchange
that's the world's second largest but
nobody knew this go up a couple years
and I'm a senior in college and people
say what are going to do when you get
out of school Larry
they said want me to be working at the
Mercantile Exchange they go that's great
can you get me in I have to buy a sofa
and I and this happened more than once
they have to say no it's not the
merchandise smart and they go what's the
difference and imagine trying to explain
to your future father-in-law what you're
going to do for a living and how you're
going to support his daughter but
fortunately in 1972 there was some
activity in cattle and there was a lot
of protests I forgot whether that was
the year prices were too high or too low
but suddenly the other channels in
Chicago the news teams had stock footage
of the trading floor and then people
would say are you one of those people
who just goes down and shouts in waves
your hands and you'd say yes and they
would walk away they had a sense of what
you did so I think that plus of the
currency trading really helped change
things and I think today if you called
up channel 9 they'd have a massive
collection of stock footage of the
trading floors and that really started
to change things but up until the 70s
the only schools that taught anything
about futures trading where the
land-grant colleges University of
Illinois Iowa and that would be in the
agricultural economics department there
was one book on the futures business if
you walked into any bookstore up until
really the early 1970s May
even the mid-70s there was nothing at
all on futures trading you'd have to
look very very hard and so that became
part of my mission was to help educate
and become a cheerleader for the
industry well and in the 80s you taught
classes right and when there was a much
bigger interest in futures when people
thought that they could come to Chicago
and make a mint right and $1,000 at
lunch definitely I was on the Education
Committee for the Chicago Mercantile
Exchange in the mid 70s and we noticed
that there was a huge number of summer
employees coming in and granted many of
them were children and nieces and
nephews of members but people want to
know what they were doing if they just
didn't want to go down there and you
know okay run this order you know answer
this phone so I was part of a committee
that created a one class and
introduction to futures and uh it was so
well received that the exchange well
maybe we should be doing this on a
regular basis and they eventually built
a catalogue of about two dozen classes
that were offered a quarterly basis and
I kind of took over
introduction to futures and a few other
courses options for beginners we would
have so many people taking this course
in the summer that we would have to rent
out the little auditorium at the Civic
Opera House and people were moving to
Chicago to learn about this business
that there was no electronic trading and
if you wanted to really know futures you
had to be on the floor there was no two
ways about it I would have at the time
you know now we're moving into the early
1980s mid 1980s I was running the retail
futures department for Dean Witter
Reynolds I would he have MBA graduates
come to me saying I'll move to Chicago I
will work for minimum wage 30 hours a
week which you know part-time work as a
runner just to learn the business and
you know their intention was to leave
after a few months and I that was fine
by me but they needed to get down they
needed to make their connections meet
people understand how it works and you
wound up with suddenly situation where
you were no longer there because you
were somebody's son or daughter and
niece or nephew but because you had an
advanced degree and you saw the
potential for all of this thank you and
it's at the risk of being tumor kevie I
want to target one other person Nancy
you were good yeah
arguably I know there's some debate the
first woman to walk on the floor of the
oh yeah James right I was the first
woman who was allowed on the floor at
the Mercantile Exchange that was in 1962
in fact the mercantil Chicago Mercantile
was the first exchange in the country to
allow women members and my husband
wanted to open his own business and so
he chose me as his partner and bought a
membership for me and of course at that
time they were really anxious to sell
memberships to you know whoever had came
along so they were willing to sell one
to a woman and the first day that I went
to after I went before the board
government was approved my husband said
to me well now you have to go out on the
floor and at that time they didn't even
allow women employees and so we took the
elevator and we went down I kept saying
to them that women aren't allowed
you know women aren't allowed and when
we got to the gate the guard who used to
be there said oh no no Nancy can't go
out on the floor and he ran forever
Harris the President and he said oh yes
and she can of course in the meantime
bud just let you know let me out on the
floor but so I was the first woman to go
out on the exchange floor during trading
hours and there were some long faces
looking looking at me put all of buds
you know friends congratulated me and
that that was the end of that and then I
think it was probably a few months maybe
six now and I didn't go down and answer
the phones for a while
forum and work at the desk but you know
I had four very young children at home
and you know it didn't work out so I
think in a few more months maybe six
months after that they did allow that
someone did start working a woman did
start working down on the floor and from
that point on it was history and then
actually build cousins it was a woman in
the Eurodollar pit and perhaps the most
successful female trader arguably the
most successful woman floor trader in
history I would say she did very very
well in the she had a great mind for
mathematics and she could do numbers so
well she traded the back month spreads
in the euro dollar contract which is one
of those things that when I started this
book when people said things like back
months of breads I just write
essentially that just means Eurodollar
futures contracts are basically you're
trading the very short-term interest
rates I'm going to stop you there
because people who understand you
understand you and people who don't
understand okay yeah so is any other
questions if not I hope you get a chance
to mingle and talk to people because
there's some really fascinating people
here Charlie Andrews is the whole start
of the book the whole end of the book is
about Charlie he came in from Kansas
which I so appreciate he he's a really
interesting guy board of trade people
who may have gotten the shaft in this
conversation I'm sure I have interesting
things and I just I really appreciate
you welcoming it's really sweet and
Charlie and what about his uncle when
the cattle market really started to boom
all the Cowboys wanted to come to town
to see what was going on there was a
fella by the name of Frank booth who ran
the biggest Truck Line cattle bull
hauler in the
States from Greenland Frank had this
much height on being a hundred pounds
and he came to buy a seat but they told
him why don't we get you a yellow jacket
and let you get the feel of this before
you buy a seat and so here was this
giant old man among all these young
runners running around the floor and
everybody was whispering who is he who
is he who is he his Uncle Bill called
him over to Pitt and he said Sonny I see
your little older and bigger than most
of these runners so to get you on the
same plane I'm just going to buy you a
Boy Scout knife his dad had the greatest
sixth sense of the market of anybody
Muirfield backed me up they were out on
a new yacht and the yacht sank and they
were on this life raft and on the second
day his dad David disclosed to his wife
the worst part of this is I'm sure the
soybeans are limit down today it was a
great great humor that happened among
all the things but what we built is a
gigantic market of the world and it's
going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and I'm really pushing Emily to
come out with the next book because we
have to have counterparty risk it cannot
go off into derivatives into thin air
and we must have the contracts designed
or redesigned to fit the marketplace
today but this place will grow like
nobody can ever imagine
today they traded almost a hundred
thousand cows
big day we ever had was 35 the chordal
trade 400 to 500 thousand contracts a
day we couldn't get over 50 thousand in
the pit because physically we couldn't
handle it
electronics are putting us into the
future but the big thing to remember
there's four hundred and eight million
people in North America and maybe
maximum two hundred million people in
South America outside of our boundaries
are six billion people you got two sides
of the hemisphere were the food
producers of the world and they're the
producers of industrial products and we
developed a swap market which is what I
learned how to do swaps there which is
the most valuable things I could have
ever learned in my life and we will
propel we will build jobs around the
food industry just like China with their
17 vital trace elements will build steel
and all of these things but it's got to
be a world of swaps or it's World War
three and we nuke each other out and I
have to say at the when I started
writing this I would have no idea what
you just said so hopefully if you read
the book you'll you'll go back and say
ah now I know what Charlie's talking
about because they'd started is very
simple markets they grew into something
that sounds much more complex and sounds
scary but Charlie knows all this because
he knew it when you'd be traded cattle
and it's there really is a progression
so that what he says starts to make
sometimes okay thanks again everyone for
coming we're open for several more hours
so I hope you'll stay and have some wine
some food Emily here is what is
graciously agreed to sign some books and
so we're going to start that right now
and thank you both that was really
fascinating thank you thank you Joe
[Applause]
Emily Lambert is a senior writer at
Forbes magazine for more information and
to read her blog visit blogs dot
forbes.com slash Emily Lambert